Just before we get started,
I do want to say that this video is brought to you by me,
or rather another channel that I do called business plays. It's about business,
but it's fun by if you're wondering what goes on here. Danny writes the scripts.
I read them and react to them.
Occasionally I give them a little Slack because why not?
It looks at the most Epic failures and times things went wrong,
but also little known successes.
I guess these are like stakes where rich people, exactly what I'm talking about.
Generally, just the weirdest stuff that I could find from the business world.
Like why you found note in the UK, mostly for criminal, stuff like that.
It's more laid back than this. Sorry.
I get good amounts of silliness and fun of you along with some facts.
Check it out through the link below and let's get into today's video.
Find smart.
A few and score big. That was the credo, which going to English pirate,
Samuel Black, Sam Belleny.
He was sometimes called the Prince of pirates because he treated both his crew
and his captives with fairness and mercy,
but also because he liked to dress in fancy clothes and exhibited polite
manners.
He also called himself the Robin hood of the sea while his crew were Robin
Hood's men, while he certainly took from the rich,
he didn't go so far as to give to the poor. He was still a pirate after rule.
This strategy of being a benevolence buck and near was not one adopted by many
other pirate captain.
So you prefer to rule over the seas through Dara and chaos,
but it is certainly one that worked for Bellamy. Despite a very short career.
He may have ended it as the richest pirates in history with modern estimates,
placing as wealth at around $120 million.
Probably won't surprise you to learn that we don't know much about Bellamy's
early years. And what we do know is a mixture of facts.
Certainness rumors and legends.
Samuel Bellamy was born circa 1689 to Steven and Elizabeth Bellamy and the small
parish of hideously and Devin England.
Some sources suggest March the 18th is the date of his birth,
but others indicate that Elizabeth Bellamy died giving birth to Samuel sometime
in February and the March, the 18th have been. In fact,
the date of his baptism developing is on six children together.
Although their only other son had already died by the time Samuel was born,
this would have meant that the family farming cottage would have gone to him,
but young Samuel had no inclination to become a farmer and work the land.
Therefore he left home as soon as he was able and looks to the calmer sailor.
Allegedly Samuel had become enamored with life on the sea from tales,
detaining the adventures of Henry.
Every another famous piratey proceeded him by a few decades and had been born in
the same County, a short distance away from hit asleep.
Despite Bellamy's young age and complete lack of experience,
he would not have found it difficult to secure a spot, a board, a ship.
This was during the height of maritime travel and both the Royal Navy and
private merchant vessels were on the lookout for young sailors.
They needed only been exacerbated by the start of the war of Spanish in
1701. That same year, the 13 year old Bellamy.
He secured a position as a ship's boy aboard a matching vessel.
He spent the entire war at sea working his way up through the ranks.
The conflict ended in 1714. And while we have no records of the positions,
Samuel Bellamy, Aldons the ships he served on by the time the war was over,
he was an experienced Seder sometime around 17, 15.
He made his way to the new world and traveled to Cape Cod in Massachusetts,
that he allegedly made the acquaintance of a young woman by the name of Mary or
Maria Hallot. He charms her with tales of maritime adventures,
and the two spent a night together afterwards. They wanted to wear it,
but her parents who were wealthy landowners would not allow their daughter to
marry a poor sailor from then on Bellamy swore that he would go out into the
world, make his fortune and return to marry his beloved. As far as we can tell,
Mary Hollis never met Bellamy again,
but she ends in new England's law in her own way is the sea,
which of Billingsgate. According to legends,
Mary became pregnant following her encounter with a future pirate months later
on a cold winter night,
she was found in a bond and a counselor's Sonic stage cradling a dead baby in
her arms. It was the belief of the entire community.
The younger that killed her loved child. So obviously she needed to be punished.
First. She was taken to the middle of town, tied to a post and webs afterwards.
She was imprisoned and tortured daily until the arrival of a trial where she
would surely have been found guilty and executed every day.
The town filled with Mary's wailing and screaming.
The girl pleaded with a capitalist to simply let her die,
but they refused one day a visitor approached Mary's cell.
He was a well-dressed well-spoken man with a gold tip walking cane.
He talked with Mary and convinced her that the entire world hated her and wanted
to make her suffer. That's how rage grew.
The mountain produced a contract and made her an offer.
She couldn't refuse her freedom and to Sean's for revenge by simply signing on
the dotted line. And on that day,
Mary Hallot sold her soul to the devil and it became the sea witch of
Billingsgate. From that point on the,
which lived inside a whale that carried a ship's light on its tail.
She used the lights to Nour ships onto lands where the sea,
which would prey on the unsuspecting sailors,
taking their lives and their souls in a different version of the story.
People tell about ghost,
which can sometimes still be seen on the shores of Cape Cod,
as she waits for her lover to return to her.
Okay.
Developing.
He was now faced with the same dilemma that troubled many sailors of his time
with the war over there were significantly fewer opportunities than the were
before. However, the only thing Belamine knew how to do was sailor ship,
many other seamen who found themselves in the situation thought they had no
alternative, but to turn to piracy,
but this was not actually the immediate decision taken by Bellamy.
That first he wanted to be a treasure Hunter. During his time in new England,
Bellamy made the acquaintance of a silversmith named Paul Graves Williams or
Paul's grave, or simply Paul. He was older than Bellamy,
almost 40 years old and prominent family that was descended from English
royalty. How are they? His stepfather had involved in some shady dealings,
such as smuggling and the black markets and his closing of the law rubbed off on
Williams and his siblings, allegedly Paul's sister,
even married a man named Edward sands.
He was a friend of the notorious pirate captain kids.
And the couple even helped him set his contraband.
Therefore just like Bellamy Williams grew a desire to leave his wife and
children behind and set sail for adventure. Cool. Listen,
18th century version of a midlife crisis. Anyway,
he met Bellamy and the two bonded over their mutual disaster escapades on the
high seas. But like we said,
they didn't immediately decide to become pirates that fast.
They wanted to try their luck at salvaging treasure.
They even had a prize in mind, the Spanish treasure fleet earlier that year,
a fleet of 12 Spanish ships left Havana headed for Spain.
And they were all filled with gold, silver jewels coins, and other valuables.
They encountered a hurricane there's 11 of those ships were sunk off the coast
of Florida taking wisdom, all of that treasure ever since then,
people like Belamine Williams gushed over the idea of recovering even a small
fraction of that news and living like Kings,
the duo entered a partnership together with Bellamy's sailing know-how and
Williams as money and connections.
They would assemble a crew and try to salvage one of the Spanish ships while
they found out for when they got there was that every other sailor in salvage in
the region had the same idea. Many had even been hot by the Spanish crown,
which was desperately trying to regain its valuable cargo that let me in
Williams alongside all the other crews in the area worked for a few months,
but with little success,
they found some coins in jewels that had been taken by currents and made their
way to the ocean floor,
but they couldn't locate the main whole section of the ship,
which would have contained the bulk of the loot by early 17,
16 Spanish reinforcements arrived in the area and they drove away all the
independent treasure hunters like Bellamy and Williams.
Their expedition had been a complete failure and they hated the idea of going
back to new England empty handed.
It was only one solution that was left to them and it was piracy.
[Inaudible].
So both Bellamy and Williams hoisted the black flag and became pirates.
The former became known as black Sam Bellamy.
Although he probably first attains the nickname back in new England.
Allegedly people called him this because he did not like wearing those large
white pounded wigs and instead preferred to let his own long black half flow,
tying it back with a simple bands.
He and Williams first traveled to central America to the Gulf of Honduras,
where they recruited men to join that crew.
Of course they would also need a ship and it's like most pirates.
They started out small Williams and Bellamy,
both commanded watercraft scored perianal, GWAS. They were small,
but good enough to get the job done. Soon afterwards,
they managed to take the first problems in the region.
A Dutch merchant ship afterwards came another prize and English sloop commanded
by captain young, they use the ship to travel to Cuba,
tying off their ships to the sides of the vessel.
That's only in Cuba did not start off or spaciously.
The first ships they encountered were a group of four.
Sloops flying the English flag under the of captain Henry Jennings.
The pirates were outnumbered and outgunned,
so they had no intention of provoking a fight. Instead they gave captain young,
his ship back climbs into their ships and rode there.
Little heart sounds into shallow waters where they knew the snoops couldn't
follow them. Only later did they learn that Jennings himself was also a pirate.
So he had no interest in pursuing them,
but he did plunge that captain young ship off to this Lisel incidence,
the two crews disbanded for a short time.
It seems like Bellamy's pirate Korea would. And as soon as it started,
but as fortunately, this took a turn for the better.
When he and Williams met captain Benjamin Horner gold,
by that point on a gold was already a famous and feared pirate in those waters.
It also taken on an apprentice named Edward teach,
who would become better known as the notorious Blackbeard in the near future.
We've already done a video about him. You can easily find that on our channel.
Anyway, he decided there was room for two more men aboard his fleet.
So Bellamy and Williams joined his crew soon enough Balam he began impressing
everyone with his nautical skills and knowledge.
It became evidence that he was one of the most talented sailors in horny Gold's
crew and started climbing through the ranks very quickly. In fact,
in just a few months,
even though Bellamy was young and the junior member of the crew, I want to,
Gold's named him acting captain of one of the smaller ships ahead of others who
had seniority over him. This was a productive period for Bellamy.
He claims numerous prizes as part of horny Gold's crew.
His fleet also aligned itself with the other French pirates at VA level,
also known as laborious or the buzzard together.
They formed quite a formidable maritime force.
Levasseur himself was an interesting character.
Whether you have a quick mention, he amassed a large treasure as a pirate,
but was then caught and hanged in 1730 on the day of his execution.
While sitting on the gallows, let us, uh,
through a piece of parchment into the crowd saying that his treasure would
belong to the one who will understand his message.
The parchment was a treasure map and the form that they 17 line cryptogram ever
since then people have been looking for.
The hidden loot is generally believed to be buried on the islands of may in the
Seychelles, but the mysterious cryptogram still remains unsolved.
So back to Bellamy, his association with of gold didn't last long,
the latter steadfastly refused to attack English ships.
We don't know if this was out of a sense of patriotism or if it was because he
wanted to claim that he was still a privateer in service of England's and not a
full-on pirate either way. While if you doesn't have horn,
a Gold's men might have held similar views. The vast majority did not.
And this was a serious cause of frustration among the crew.
The tension reached fever pitch during the summer of 1716,
while holding a gold wins on a trip to The Bahamas, taking only his own ship,
the adventure during that time,
Bellamy and Levison ignored his mandate and took several English prizes.
When horny gold refused and found out he was furious,
but he soon discovered that most of his crew did not share his feelings.
Eventually the men had had enough and wanted horny gold relieved of his command.
A vote was taken and over three quarters of the men went against their now
former captain. More than that though,
they voted black Sam Bellamy as their new permanent around two dozen men stayed
loyal to horn gold and set sail alone on one of the sloops while the rest of
Ireland themselves, between the cruise of Bellamy. And let us sit up.
Paul Williams became Bellamy's new quartermaster.
[Inaudible].
Bellamy's a sense of power.
Was something truly remarkable that had seldom been seen in maritime history,
even among pirates, who were, you know,
a bit looser on the old rules and regulations less than a year had passed since
it left new England in the hopes of maybe making a living as a salvager.
And now he was captain of his own ship with over 90 men under his command for
the arranger of the Bellamy sailed together with liver syrup.
They were a formidable duo and took numerous prizes.
There were occasions when the pirates captured two ships in a single date,
Bellamy would end his career as a pirate captain with over 50 prizes to his
name.
And most of them occurred during this time period among them was a British much
and Galilee called the Sultana, which became Bellamy's new flagship.
While Williams was given command of his previous vessel. The Maryanne of course,
this kind of success did not go unnoticed for long.
This was around the time that woods Rogers,
the governor of The Bahamas vowed to get rid of piracy in his region.
And it's successfully petitioned to obtain several British warships to protect
his waters in early 17, 17. Now rant,
his men concluded that it was time to seek safest seas.
So they set sail for South America. Now, then he did not follow them though.
Instead it was preferred to be able to stand and fight against the powerful
British frigates, but for that he needed a bigger, stronger ship.
He needed the widow galley. It was named after the kingdom of Witter,
an African coastal territory today known as Benin back then it's as a major
slave trading area.
And the ship itself was commissioned by a wealthy London slave merchant and
member of parliament names, Humphry Morris to serve as a slave galley.
There would a galley left on its maiden voyage from England in early 17, 16,
and traveled to Africa to collect slaves and valuables such as gold and ivory.
The ship was captained by Lawrence Prince,
a Dutch officer who previously served as a privateer under captain Henry Morgan.
It then went to the Caribbean where it traded for other commodities,
such as rum, sugar, dyes, and spices in February 17, 17, the Witter gallery.
It was on its way back to England to do this though,
attempted to reverse the treacherous waters of Cuba and The Bahamas,
which were known to be rifle with pirates even.
So captain Prince was confident that his ship had the speed and maneuverability
to deal with whatever peril it might encounter.
Eventually what he expected to happen happens.
Prince notice that there were two ships following him,
a warship and a sleep of walk. At first,
he hoped that these might be British vessels coming out of Jamaica,
but he soon realized that he was being chased by pirates.
It was black Sam Bellamy in the Sultana followed closely by Williams,
bought the Marianne captain Prince decided that his best course of action was to
run. His ship was faster. So he should have been able to escape.
The chase lasted three days and covered 300 miles of open water.
But through superior seamanship the pirates managed to cap shop to the way to
Ganni now came an important for Bellamy.
He was fairly certain that he had the firepower to defeat the slave ship,
but an all out battle with not only have damaged his own two vessels,
but also the craft that he intended to commandeer. They were also in open water.
So they wouldn't have been able to make any serious repairs. Of course,
this last thought was also on Prince's mind.
You realize that a fire has a great chance of sinking his ship that far off to
adjust a couple of token Canon shots. He surrendered afterwards.
He was relatively relieved to discover that Bellamy lived up to his reputation
as a merciful captain.
The Pirate's mood was undoubtedly improved when he discovered that the cargo
holds, if the Witta galley,
it contained chests filled with tens of thousands of gold coins,
which represented the entire hole from the ships trading expedition,
Bellamy transferred all the cargo from the salt Arno to the widow.
Also adding 10 cannons to the 18 already presence even allowed Princeton is
meant to keep the sole Taner tolerance at sail England.
Although this was mainly because Bellmead didn't have the crew to fully Nan
three ships.
[Inaudible].
At this point,
black Sam Bellamy was captain of one of the most powerful ships on the sea whose
cargo hold was filled with treasure.
It may have been a smart move to get out while he was on top.
But the temptation for further riches,
fame and glory was just too much after talking it over with the crew.
Bellamy decided to, to travel to the Eastern coast of North America,
starting from New York and going down to the Carolinas,
the pirates took several prizes. During this time.
One of them was the Ann galley,
which she added to his fleet under the command of his quartermaster.
Richard Nolans another was a sleep commanded by captain beer or beers,
but let me wants it to return commands of the plunder ship to the captain.
But his crew out voted him in favor of sinking it out of spice because they
refuse to join them.
This inspired a speech where Bellamy espoused his hatred of the rich English
aristocracy. We have no idea if there is any historical accuracy to it,
but it represents a memorable moments.
Nonetheless Bellamy saying to Bayer though, you are a sneaking puppy.
And so will all those who will submit to be governed by laws,
which rich men have made for their own security for the cowardly wild stuff,
not to the courage otherwise to defend once they get by neighbory,
but you altogether Dan them for a pack of crafty Rascals,
and you who serve them for a parcel of hen hot at numbskulls.
They vilify us the scoundrels do when there is only this difference.
They robbed the poor under the cover of law for sooth.
And we plunge the rich under the protection of our own courage.
How do you not about a MIGS?
Then one of us then sneak off to these villains for employments Bellamy's Korea
and his life. For that matter ended abruptly, unexpectedly and violently,
and April 17,
17 poles grave Williams made a stop to visit his family and probably share some
of his plumbed up during that time, the way to galley headed for new England,
according to legends, Bellamy intended to see his love and Mary Hallis.
But we don't know if this is true either way. He did not make it on the 26th.
The ship was caught in a powerful storm near what is today,
Wellfleet Massachusetts,
the Moss broke and the way to galley and to shallow waters where it capsized and
sank quickly only two men of the 146 on board. The ship survived.
Samuel Bellamy was not one of them around a hundred bodies washed up on the
shore and were buried in a mass grave.
But 40 of them remained unaccounted for people flocked to the beaches near the
rack, his coins, jewels and other valuables were brought in by the tides.
However,
the location of the ship wreck itself remained a mystery for almost 270 years.
It wasn't until 1994,
that maritime archeologist Barry Clifford tracked down the remnants of the wit
of galley back then such discoveries from the golden age of piracy were still
almost unheard of the following year covered in his team,
recovered the ship's bell, which had the words, the word, a galley, 17,
16 inscribed on us,
thus proven conclusively that the wreck was once the flagship of black Sam
Bellamy, we were got a gallery.
It became the first step of pirate shipwreck authenticated beyond any doubt in
the decades that followed over 200,000 individual items have been recovered from
the wreck. This included lots of treasures, such as gold coins,
but archeologists were more interested in the personal items that revealed to us
new notions about the pirates in the golden age. For example,
it had been reported that among Bellamy's crew,
there was a young boy named John King,
who was only 10 or 11 years old in the rank of divers recovered the shoe silk
stocking,
and most disturbing of all the leg bone of a boy that age seemingly proving not
only that John King existed, but that he perished alongside all the others.
As far as Bellamy himself is concerned, his remains still allude us.
His body was not among those that washed ashore.
And it was believed back in 2018 that divers may have found his bones in the
wreckage alas, a DNA sample was compared against that of living descendants.
And it was not a match lack. Sam Bellamy,
still arrests somewhere in Davy Jones' locker to this very day.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button. Also, please do check of another channel.
I mentioned business plays,
which I will link to below and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].